[Music]
you are a very proud West Virginian
we've talked about this before but you
talk about West Virginia in this way you
wax rhapsodic about West Virginia you
seem to really doesn't most everyone
know just that we don't know that much
about you grow up there I grew up in
West Virginia it's just a beautiful
beautiful place and it's a it's one of
the places that really has a sense of
place about it you get when you're there
you're not anywhere else not
Massachusetts you know like I don't know
Massachusetts like do you know your
state bird no I don't I'm thinking about
it but I honestly don't know the state
bird and Matt I mean Cardinal do you
know just wait I'll see you know your
stats yours the Cardin the tree the tree
I don't know it's probably dead the fish
the fish is a card
I'm sure it's a car brook trout do you
know your state butterfly monarch do you
know your state insect um honeybee do
you know
do you know the state song do you want
to hear it yeah make sure the state song
I want to hear the West Virginia say you
sing this on Christmas Eve at church
after doing all of the after doing the
silent night this is what religious wait
a minute so you sing silent night about
the coming of the Savior and then you
all break into the state song oh the
West Virginia Hills how majestic and how
grand with their summits bathed in glory
like our Prince Emmanuel slammed is it
any wonder then that my heart with
rapture thrills when I stand once more
with loved ones in the West Virginia
Hills over those tales beautiful Hills
beautiful hills beautiful Hill Virginia
Hills
that's impressive that you know the song
my favorite part is the part where
you're clearly hearing other voices in
your head
is insane
let me mention butter I love what this
movies about it's about a a butter
carving contest which is actually a real
thing it's a famous event yes it's a
huge thing it's it's um at most state
fairs there's a butter carving contest
and particularly in the middle of the
country I know I think has a big one is
it this this one takes place that this
movie takes place in Iowa at the Iowa
State Fair and it's just an enormous
deal and there are food sculptors in
this country making good livings you
know sculpting things right Jim Victor
was our resident food sculptor he came
and taught the cast and he sculpts
butter he sculpts chocolate he made a
blinkin out of pepperoni cheese which he
says smells very bad yeah I would think
so yes so you get rid of all these
sculptures within an hour of them being
done you I mean you spend a long time on
them they have to be done in
refrigerated big glass cases and they're
beautiful works of art butter is so fun
to sculpt I can't recommend it enough if
someone's holding a gun to your head
did I'm sure is it sensual to get your
hands in butter I would think it'd be a
sensual aspect to it but I'm kind of
pervy I just think it's not because it's
you don't do it when it don't be freaky
you look so weird
I'm getting my handy butter